Adam Levine's new maroon 5 songs  featuring Kendrick Lamar is out and it  goes a little something like this don't  wanna no no no no shaking you track his  polls don't want to know and it comes  just three weeks after Adam and his wife  Behati Prinsloo welcomed their first  baby a daughter named dusty rose she's  an angel she was born in Angela we were  born to be a parent that's what we're  here for really Adam really hit the high  notes in the new song the music video is  slated to debut this Friday and in a  spirit of celebrating how sweet is this  snap Pahadi shared congratulating her  BFF candice swanepoel on her new baby i  was very excited